[Música]
[Aplausos]
quisiera saber cuántos de ustedes
llegaron hoy aquí en transporte público
cuando hablamos de transporte público
hablamos de diversas oportunidades
podríamos hablar de las oportunidades
que nos darán las plataformas digitales
y de cómo éstas van a impactar el
sistema de transporte público ahora y en
el futuro también podríamos hablar de
cómo podemos pasar a flota vehicular
eléctrica y los impactos positivos que
tendríamos en la huella de carbono en
nuestro país también podríamos hablar de
las oportunidades que tiene el sistema
de mejor integral
pero el día de hoy quisiera hablarles de
algo que casi no se habla y es como el
transporte público juega un rol
fundamental en la lucha contra la
pobreza y la pobreza extrema
todos aquí creo hemos oído de alguna u
otra acción para poder luchar contra la
pobreza extrema pero hay o difícil que
alguno de ustedes haya oído como el
transporte público es clave para esta
lucha y cómo podemos incorporarlo y
desarrollarlo en la lucha contra la
pobreza en la búsqueda de oportunidades
y en la búsqueda de equidad
y es que miles de costarricenses todos
los días dependen de su conectividad y
del transporte público para poder ir a
sus centros educativos para poder ir a
trabajar para poder ir a una cita médica
para buscar más y mejores oportunidades
para ellos mismos y para su familia y
mucho de estas oportunidades dependerán
de donde viven y de qué tan cerca están
de las redes de conectividad transporte
público
quisiera contarles cuatro historias que
yo creo que ejemplifican muy bien como
el transporte público tiene un impacto
positivo o negativo en la búsqueda de
las oportunidades para una vida mejor
juan es un hombre joven vive en un
asentamiento informal fuera del gran
área metropolitana fue excluido del
sistema educativo pero él quiere
regresar a las aulas
sabe que si logra sacar el bachillerato
puede conseguir un futuro mejor para él
y ayudarle a su madre que es jefa de
hogar
juanse averigua de cuál es el colegio
nocturno más cercano que queda a su casa
cuál es el problema
bueno vive muy lejos de la parada de bus
y justamente los horarios de la ruta de
bus no coinciden con la salida del
colegio nocturno por ende no puede
acceder al colegio 'juan es pobre de
acceso
laura es empleada doméstica todos los
días tiene una ruta diferente
dependiendo de a dónde tiene que ir a
trabajar usualmente le toma
aproximadamente hora y media estándar de
su casa a su primer punto de trabajo
pero como son varios usualmente tiene
que tomar varios buses este mes la hora
tiene que pagar diez mil colones en
medicamentos esto hace toda la
diferencia en su economía mensual por
ende lo que va a hacer este mes es que
va a caminar más para ahorrarse algunos
pases de buses
esto aunado a que tiene que trabajar de
manera física arduamente más las horas
que invierte en el transporte público
más todo lo que tiene que caminar la
deja agotada al final del día eso domina
su productividad en el trabajo la hora
es pobre de energía
pablo es el orgulloso padre de tres
hijos es proactivo muy trabajador
siempre busca cómo llevarle sustento a
su familia y por ende siempre está
trabajando usualmente para llegar al
trabajo que tiene ahora tiene que salir
a las seis de la mañana para poder
asegurarse estar ahí antes de las ocho
en punto
a la hora de la salida más o menos a las
6 de la tarde y como ahorita estamos en
época lluviosa se puede tardar hasta dos
horas para regresar a su casa
eso significa que pablo tiene que salir
a las seis y regresa aproximadamente a
las ocho a las ocho y media de la noche
su casa casi no puede ver a sus tres
hijos muchas veces los fines de semana
también tiene que trabajar siente que se
le están haciendo muy grandes porque los
niños crecen muy rápido y él no nos
puede ver desearía tener menos tiempo
pegado en una presa y estar más tiempo
con sus hijos pablo es pobre de tiempo
carmen anna y verónica son tres mujeres
de una generación luchadora una familia
luchadora cármenes adulta mayor tiene un
desgaste de cadera pero aún así tiene
que trabajar para salir de su casa y
tomar el bus tiene que subir una cuesta
bastante alta muchas veces no lo logra
ya que tiene muchísimo dolor en la
cadera y esos días no puede ir a
trabajar
anna es la hija de carmen ella es
dependiente en la avenida central cuando
le toca horario nocturno y sale
aproximadamente a las 8 9 de la noche ha
sido víctima de acoso ha sido víctima de
violencia verbal ha sido víctima hasta
de tocamientos
veronica es hija de anna tiene 14 años
camina ida y vuelta al colegio todos los
días
ya está acostumbrada porque
lamentablemente lo hemos normalizado los
piropos que le gritan desde los carros
cuando ella va caminando por la calle
pero realmente lo que más le preocupa es
que tiene que atravesar un puente que no
tiene baranda por donde los carros pasan
muy rápidamente y en dos ocasiones ha
estado a punto de caerse
carmen ana y verónica no solamente son
víctimas de la pobreza de acceso de
energía y de tiempo estas tres mujeres
como muchas otras son pobres de
seguridad
y en esta pobreza quisiera detenerme
porque cuando hablamos de las
poblaciones más vulnerables de los
vulnerables hablamos de las mujeres de
los niños de las niñas de nuestra
población adulta mayor y de nuestra
población con discapacidad a estas
poblaciones sobre todo si están en
niveles de pobreza por esa extrema las
penalizamos dos veces
también es importante decir que dentro
de esta población de los vulnerables más
vulnerables tenemos que sumarle que los
patrones de movilidad entre los hombres
y las mujeres son completamente
distintos las mujeres socialmente
seguimos teniendo el cuido de los niños
de los adultos mayores las labores
domésticas y el trabajo fuera de casa
muchísimo más de nuestro lado que del
lado de los hombres entonces las mujeres
hacemos más trayectos hacemos trayectos
más cortos trabajamos y subimos más de
las rutas de buses hacemos trayectos en
hora pico donde hay mucha presa en hora
valle donde los horarios de los buses
son más irregulares y en general para
nosotras las mujeres independientemente
de nuestra clase socioeconómica
transportarnos es más caro es más
inseguro y tardamos más tiempo
trasladándonos que los hombres
esto se vuelve un poco dramático cuando
hablamos de que el 43% de nuestros
hogares en pobreza y pobreza extrema son
jefeados por mujeres y que estas
familias en el mayor nivel de
vulnerabilidad están mujeres luchadoras
que tienen que sacar adelante a sus
hijos tienen que invertir hasta el 25%
de lo que logran hacer mensualmente
solamente en transporte eso es el
equivalente de que una familia clase
media que pueda tener un millón de
colones mensual de ingreso dedicará
250.000 al mes sólo en pases
esto realmente tiene una afectación
importante en la economía ya frágil de
estas familias
aquí podemos ver dos ejemplos de esto la
manchita amarilla es una población
en estado de vulnerabilidad y esta
población en su centro para poder llegar
al punto de conexión de bus más cercano
que es la línea roja que está en la
parte de arriba tendría que caminar 8 km
o para llegar al centro de salud más
cercano tendría que caminar tres
kilómetros
o esta otra población en rivas de pérez
zeledón en donde para llegar al punto
más cercano de conexión con la red de
transporte tienen que caminar 5.8 km
caminar 8.3 km para el centro de salud
más cercano
cómo están estas personas accediendo a
las oportunidades
de estas 4 pobrezas todos somos víctimas
en algún momento de nuestras vidas hemos
padecido de falta de tiempo de falta de
energía
y falta de acceso en algunos casos de
falta de seguridad
la poca calidad de vida que tenemos con
el sistema de movilidad actual que
estamos llevando tenemos que empezar a
entender el transporte la planificación
urbana el acceso digno a vivienda y
dónde se encuentra esa vivienda
relacionada con los puntos de servicios
y de redes como una herramienta poderosa
contra la lucha contra la pobreza
la pregunta es bueno qué podemos hacer
para llevar mayor acceso a la gente con
pequeños cambios podemos hacer realmente
toda la diferencia y me gustaría que
doña novia les cuente un poco al
respecto
bueno yo vivía en el precario la espalda
bueno donde yo vivía éste había aguas
negras pasaban por al frente de mi casa
ratas que puede ver en mi casa y el
cambio de ahora de mi casa
muy diferente en todo aspecto ver las
condiciones es tan linda las calles la
casa la comodidad
todo el transporte que está al frente de
mi casa cuando vamos a comprar muy
bonito cuando yo tenía que subir las
gradas para ir al pal y a comprar
teníamos que subir las comidas
y ha sido un cambio muy lindo para mí mi
familia
cómo podemos seguir potenciando este
cambio cómo podemos hacerlo mayor cómo
podemos escalar lo tenemos que cambiar
de paradigma y tenemos que cambiar a una
metodología de desarrollo que se llama
desarrollo orientado al transporte esto
básicamente es tomar dos mundos que
históricamente han estado separados y
unirlos de una manera coherente para dar
respuestas la planificación urbana el
acceso a vivienda donde ubicamos los
servicios públicos
la red de transporte público
aunado a esto y teniendo estas redes
tenemos que identificar la densificación
solo es estratégica si va a una a un
sistema de transporte público le genera
mayor demanda hace que más personas
vivan cerca de estos puntos de
conectividad nos garantizamos así
también que haya más usos mixtos no
solamente en la diversidad de usos sino
también en los estratos socioeconómicos
que puedan tener acceso a estas redes
la digitalización definitivamente es una
de las armas más poderosas que tenemos
no solamente para tener una visión
descentralizada y descarbonizada sino
porque muchas veces la mejor movilidad
es la que no se hace si logramos que
todos los procesos que todos los
permisos que todas o algunas de las
certificaciones puedan hacerse mediante
plataformas institucionales
digitalizadas y dotar a la población de
acceso a internet le habremos llevado
las oportunidades a la puerta de su casa
también tenemos que cambiar el paradigma
de cómo nos movilizamos dejar de poner
el carro como el break y empezar a darle
vuelta esa pirámide poner de primero a
las personas que caminan la
peatonización después de eso cómo nos
movemos de manera no motorizada y
después el transporte masivo de personas
el transporte público y empezar a
integrarlos esto se llama intermodalidad
y por último decir que este es un reto
que nadie ha resuelto no hay país
desarrollado o no desarrollado que tenga
la respuesta final porque la movilidad
evoluciona así cómo evolucionan nuestras
dinámicas sociales es un espejo de
nuestros cambios sociales
tenemos que seguir innovando tenemos que
seguir proponiendo ideas tenemos el
talento nosotros podemos hacerlo no es
un proceso fácil pero si tenemos una
visión clara y sabemos cómo priorizar
estos pasos y participamos todos y todas
no solamente habremos logrado llevarle
más oportunidades a las personas que más
lo necesitan habremos logrado algo en
búsqueda de la equidad sino que también
muchísimas más personas hoy hubieran
dicho que llegaron aquí en transporte
público muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]